So last time we left things in the middle of a model,
which was the candidate vote in model.
And what was I going to go with the whole model again,
but just to iterate a little bit,
uh,
what was different,
what was different about that model from what we saw before?
And the main thing that was different was that the candidates can not choose
their positions if you're like every voter is a potential candidate,
but you know the positions of the voters.
And let me just bring out two lessons that we left hanging last time.
I would just put them on the board to make sure they're in your notes.
So the first lesson is,
one thing we saw already last time is there can be lots of different national
whatever.
In this model there are multiple possible nationally good Deborah and his model.
And more to the point,
not all of those equilibria have the candidates crowded at the center.
All right?
We saw early on and the classic downs or median voter model that that model
predicted crowding the center.
This one doesn't.
And we'll come back to that in a second.
And a second thing we saw last time was that entry can,
if you enter on the left,
one affects of entering on the left can be to make the candidate on the rights
more likely to win.
And conversely,
if you enter on the rights you're right wing voter candidates and you enter that
can make it more likely that the left wins,
we can,
it can lead to the winner being more,
being further away from your ideal position.
And just to revisit this a little bit,
let me go back and,
and just illustrate what those two points again.
So I'll take a row further back.
This time
I'm getting nice full row.
We can see the whole of this way.
I think a road further back.
So this time we have no confusion about what left wing and right wing is all
right.
At least almost no confusion.
So,
so let me choose this row.
Okay,
this,
this railroad.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
The people in the Balkan,
they going to have to imagine that it's a penalty being in the balcony.
All right,
so this row.
All right.
And here's my left wing.
Of this row for everyone who's in front of it is almost everybody.
And here's my right wing.
Okay.
All right.
And let's try to illustrate some equilibrium we saw last time.
So in particular,
if I can get the guy in the Blue Yale shirts to stand up a second and the guy
with his computer to set up a second.
Sorry.
All right.
And let's assume all the seats are Phil Phil's for now.
So,
uh,
so know,
just to help me out a little bit since I'm doing this on the fly,
this I'm going to claim is an equilibrium.
Notice that there are two candidates standing and those is that they are not
particularly close to the center.
We have our sort of sort of a middle of the Democratic Party left candidates.
So,
uh,
I'm,
I'm tempted to give it an a get to give you a name,
but perhaps there was not.
And his,
uh,
middle of the middle of the Republican party candidates.
All right.
And this is,
this is the election.
They're going to split the votes equally if I'd,
if I'd actually chosen correctly.
All right.
Just just observe some things here.
First for this to be an equilibrium,
it better be the case that they're symmetric on left and right.
Right.
If they're not symmetric,
then uh,
it isn't even any good.
It isn't an equilibrium because one of those candidates is going to lose for
sure.
And the way we set up,
the way we set up the model,
that means that one of them will drop out.
They'll deviate to drop out.
Is that correct?
All right.
This also illustrate this.
We've already illustrated that they're not particularly close to the center.
Let's illustrate what I meant by somebody on the left causing the right ring to
win.
So if this was the,
if this was the election and who we are getting closer and closer to the
election and suddenly one of our left wing guys,
so a dentist percentage or something,
you know,
decides to end test.
So that's what it's supposed to.
This is Dennis percentage.
I mean he enters,
alright,
if Dennis Dennis Kucinich are left wing guy enters,
there might be some sort of moral victory and entering,
but the results of this will be that our right wing candidate wins.
They want to see is that if these three guys are standing,
Dennis,
I,
she's going to steal some votes from our center left candidate and cause our
center right candidate to win.
Now,
that may or may or may not be,
uh,
Mr [inaudible] intention,
but we should be aware of it.
All right?
All right.
So this is these,
this is a real effects.
Go back to the 2000 election and think about what happens when Nita entered and
do the math as it were.
All right?
Which people didn't do at the time,
harmony.
All right?
And if you,
if you were listening to the newspapers,
we could read the New York Times this morning or this to the radio this morning.
You'll find exactly the same debate is going on now in the Republican Party.
Some men actually tell it around.
It's the right wing.
This time I switch.
We just switching around.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the right way,
some people on the right of the Republican Party are saying that if it turns out
that Giuliani who currently is leading in the polls wins the Republican
nomination,
they will run a third party candidate.
And of course the debate is exactly in these terms if they run a,
a right wing,
third party candidate.
So that would be our guy over here.
All right.
Uh,
this might be,
uh,
you know,
it might,
it might have pay off in terms of other things,
but in terms of the election,
it's going to result in a Hillary winning.
All right.
Thank you.
Okay,
so we've seen these two effects.
They're very real effects when not necessarily getting people crowding the
center and we have to worry about when we enter causing the other wing to win.
All right.
This is,
this isn't a,
I'm not making a left wing right wing politics arguments here.
This is true for both wings symmetrically.
All right.
So,
uh,
let's try and bring one more idea in here,
which is where we ended up last time,
which is just how far away from the center can we be?
So these guys sit down in a second and let's stand up.
Mr [inaudible] again,
and I know it isn't a real name,
but have a mind.
Mr [inaudible] out here on the left and uh,
Mr Crazy right wing guy whose name I've,
uh,
who's the most crazy right wing guy of these candidates.
I'm not gonna I'll get in trouble wherever I name.
So whoever the most crazy right wing candidate is,
you can think of.
All right.
And then we have the full spectrum represented with the,
just the extremes standing right here.
We have this symmetric metric around the center,
right?
But I claim this is not an equilibrium.
So if people on the balcony,
I've got the extreme right and extreme left standing here.
Why is this not an equilibrium?
Yeah,
I just actually I should,
it's my fault.
I should put in the way.
Can I have the mic and I,
sorry,
my fault.
Thanks.
This one.
So Katie,
why is that not an equilibrium?
Because the person in the center could stand up and when exactly.
Cause the person in the syndicates up when actually it doesn't only have to be
the person exactly in the center,
uh,
a wide variety,
a wide array of center candidates could deviate.
And when at this point,
all right,
so this was the,
this was the,
uh,
two candidate standing and you mentioned a third candidate standing who for
example,
is this gentleman.
All right?
If he was to stand,
uh,
well how you need to be looked at close and center,
let's say,
let's say this guy,
the guy in gray,
all,
alright.
Fairly clearly.
He's going to end up,
he's going to end up winning.
All right?
All right,
so this is the third lesson.
If the candidates are too far apart,
we're going to see some center entry,
which is going to win.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
All right.
So,
even though there isn't this full downs in effects of pushing candidates towards
the center,
even though we don't have the median voter theorem here,
we still have part of the intuition surviving.
The part of the intuition that survives is if the candidates are too far apart,
then the center will enter and win.
So there is something pulling people to the center stone.
Thank you.
Ah,
AH,
not much.
I can't,
sorry,
someone to ask you how you move the podium.
I can do so a little bit.
Not much.
And retry that matter.
All right,
so a reasonable question here is just how far apart in equilibrium can the
candidates be?
We've established that we can have two candidates and they need and both be at
the center.
We've established that they can't be at the extremes.
Alright,
how far apart can they be?
How far apart can they be?
Well,
this is really just a,
it's,
it's kind of a nerdy question to get it precisely,
but let's get it precise nevertheless.
All right,
so let's have a look.
Excuse the other board.
So here's the full extent of our political spectrum from zero to one.
And let me just try and illustrate how far apart these can be.
I'm going to do is I'm going to divide this into sixth one sixth,
two,
six and a half,
four,
six,
five,
six.
All right,
so I claim and I'll show afterwards.
I'll claim that provided the two candidates aren't outside of a sick and five,
six that that will be an equilibrium.
All right?
So in particular if the candidates and just inside I'll put them just there in a
sec and just inside fires it.
So just more than a sticks and just less than five,
six,
right?
So here's one of these candidates in standing
and he was the other one.
Moby.
Okay.
Now why?
Why is that?
Why is that the right answer?
And you want 101 w word try.
I guess.
Here's the question I sent you over the weekend and I'm sure you were doing
other things over the weekend,
but nevertheless,
why is this the answer?
Well,
let's see.
Let's see.
What's,
what are they vulnerable?
They're vulnerable to deviation by somebody entering at the center.
And if somebody enters at the center,
what's what,
what would make somebody entered the center if they're going to enter the
center,
if they can win,
basically.
All right,
so if they entered the center,
in this case,
let's see how many votes everyone gets to be to talk to Sanjay here.
Here's our new canvas.
Who's thinking about entering the center?
So he's sort of thinking about it,
right?
Right.
So what's,
what's his or her calculation going to be?
Well,
let's,
let's look what would have happened.
So all of these voters,
I'm going to vote for this cat for the are left wing candidate.
So these are going to vote for the left wing candidate.
All of these voters,
oh,
going to vote for the right wing candidate,
right?
They're all closest to the right wing candidate and the middle third,
that's a third of the voters,
another third and the middle third.
These ones here,
these ones here are going to vote for the center candidate,
is that right?
So I basically divided into six.
I don't want to put everybody at the middle of a third.
All right,
so here the left wing candidate is,
is it the middle of the left third?
The right wing candidate is the middle of the right third.
How the center candidate is at the middle of the center.
Third,
I'll surprise.
Surprising.
Wait,
all right.
If he,
if they sent a candidate enters,
if they were exactly at a sick and five,
six,
they would split the vote and the center candidate would win with problems.
The one third is that right?
Alright,
but warm without worrying about that exact case.
Suppose that,
that,
that this,
as I as I claimed that the left wing candidate is just slightly to the right of
a steak and the right one candidate is just slightly to the left of five,
six.
Now this left wing candidate gets a few extra votes here and the right wing
candidate gets a few extra votes.
Yeah,
but harder.
And you can see now that the left,
the center candidate isn't going to win.
Is that right?
Cause the left wing candidates getting slightly more than a third of the votes.
The right wing candidates going to get slightly more than a third of the votes.
So the right,
so the center candidate is going to get squeezed out.
All right,
so just a little bit of thinking about it.
We can tell that that the,
in this,
in this very simple model,
the furthest apart,
the left and right wing candidates can be,
is at a stick and five,
six,
they can't go to the extremes but then not pulled all the way to the center.
All right,
so that's just,
that's just a little bit nerdy math to confirm it or no,
do you thinking about it,
but coming back to our lessons,
but I guess what we care about come out to our lessons.
The third lesson here is if the candidates,
if,
if the two candidates
kindness
are too extreme,
where Chuck's room in this model made beyond less than a second and more than
five or six,
but a too extreme.
Yeah.
Someone in the center,
we'll enzyme.
I think,
again,
if you look back in both American history and,
uh,
all the country's history,
you'll see that when candidates up perceived to be too far apart,
there's been tremendous temptation for center parties with third parties to
establish themselves in the center.
So again,
uh,
with some bias towards England,
this is what happens,
uh,
in English history during the Thatcher period,
for example,
the Thatcher government was perceived to be quite far on the right.
The Labor Party at the time was cause we've quite far on the left and we sort of
center party set up in between them.
Right.
Okay.
So these seem to be the three main politics lessons of this model.
Right?
You don't want everyone happy with that.
I'm rushing it slightly because we've said that very last time.
They weren't happy with how it works.
Okay.
There's also a game through lesson that I want to just keep in mind here
without,
well
you said
there's a game theory lesson here
and the game theory lesson is that our method of finding equilibrium in this
model,
which was what it was guessing check is actually pretty effective.
You might think that gas in shacks and so it doesn't sound like advanced
mathematics wouldn't be at such a great way of going about solving games and
thinking about them and thinking about real world,
but actually guessing.
Check did pretty well here.
We were able to make sensible guesses pretty quickly.
We were pretty quickly able to figure out what was going on and the key here,
the key here is what now without writing in a surly,
the key here is be systematic.
When you're guessing,
make sure you've looked everywhere and second,
be systematically careful when you're checking.
The big error is to ignore it,
is to ignore certain types of deviation and this particular model,
people very quickly realized that one possible deviation is for someone else to
enter,
but perhaps they're a little bit less good at spotting that.
Another possible title deviation is for somebody to drop out,
right?
You want to look at all possible types of deviation,
but bread,
you're careful.
This is a very effective method.
All right.
So that's all I want to say about this politics model.
And I want to move on to a model that perhaps has more to do with sociology's.
We did a little tour of the social sciences here and showing how game theory can
apply to each intern.
All right,
so to do that,
I'm going to,
I'll put this up
so you can still read it and work on this program.
So we're going to play another game this morning and it's going to completely
different from the Games we've played so far,
but it's still going to have lessons.
It's going to be a normal location model.
So that's the connection to what we've done before.
But the idea of this game is as follows.
We're going to imagine that there are two towns,
two possible locations,
and we'll call them east town and West town.
And we're going to assume that there are two types of people in the world.
So there's two types of people
and these types of people are tall and short.
All right?
And uh,
by deliberately,
this is arbitrary,
right?
Eastern Western kind of meaningless,
uh,
almost meaningless.
The Mantel Shelf at the towns,
I guess it says something about where they are and tall and short is we're
pretty meaningless.
The main pusher for the people that it as it said something about how tall,
loud.
All right.
The idea here is the people are going to choose where they live.
Let's assume that there's a,
you know lots of people.
There's 100,000 of each type of person and let's assume that each town holds
100,000 people.
He's a fairly big towns.
All right?
So the players in this game are going to be the people,
the 200,000 people,
200,000 talk tall people and 200,000 short people.
But in a minute I'm going to tell you whether you're tall or short.
All right?
So actually you're going to be the players in this game and the strategies are
going to be a choice of whether you choose east or west.
All right?
So these are the players
and these are going to end up being the strategies each of is going to choose,
do I want to live in the east town or do I want to live in West town?
So as usual,
what's missing is the payoffs.
All right?
And to model the payoffs,
let me first of all,
draw a picture and then come back and explain it.
Okay?
So the picture is going to look like this.
Here's the payoff picture,
and it's a little complicated.
It's just,
just bear with me for a second.
So on the horizontal access,
uh,
I'm going to put the number of people of your type in the town you end up in.
All right?
So the horizontal axis is the number of your tape
in your town.
So the most of could possibly be is 100,000,
right?
Because everybody has the same type as you and the town and the lowest it could
possibly be,
possibly be zero,
because that would,
that would say that everyone in the town,
except for you,
is of the other type.
Is that right?
And I'm going to draw this a payoff function.
This is just me.
Your pay off.
This is going to be the Tennessee or pay off
of you.
All right?
Let's just do this is type X.
Okay.
It doesn't make me mad.
I don't know if this [inaudible] as soon as he's the tall type pay off,
but to me it's gonna be some metric for the other type as well.
All right,
so the payoff is gonna look like this bit careful.
Let me draw it and that.
Explain it.
Yeah.
All right.
That goes like this and then like this.
All right,
so the idea here,
the idea is more important than the picture.
The idea is if you are a minority of one in your town to everyone else is of the
other type,
you get a payoff of zero.
All right?
If you are in the majority,
and in fact everyone in your town is offer the same type,
then you're going to pay off of a half.
And if it's the case that everyone in your town,
sorry if,
if,
if it's the case that your town is exactly mixed.
So half of your town is uh,
uh,
are tall and half of your town or short.
Then you get a payoff of one.
And I put a half fare that really the wrong thing to put here,
there should be a half of a hundred thousand.
So I guess it's 50,
it's 50,000,
right?
So just the case that 50,000 people in the town or your tape and 50,000 or the
other side,
then you get the highest possible pay off,
which is one.
So this is what we're going to assume that each and every one of you has this
payoff.
That makes sense.
All right,
so these are people,
it's a,
can I get the idea across in words?
These are people who would like to live in mixed towns,
but if they go into live in a town that's not mixed,
they'd rather live in a town in which that the majority.
That makes sense.
All right.
I'd like to live and mixed towns,
but it's a town is not making a choice between two towns.
The towns are not evenly mixed,
then they prefer to be in the majority.
So they to put the town in which that the majority.
All right,
everyone understand this,
right?
It's important since we're about to play this game,
it's important.
You're all kind of on board here.
Alright?
So to play this game,
I need to put on a few more rules.
All right?
So the first rule is going to be
okay,
but the choice is simultaneous.
And that's a little unrealistic because in practice,
of course,
people choose that towns sequentially when they,
whenever they happened to be moving.
But for the moment,
let's leave it as the hap.
And second,
I need to just say what happens if too many people choose the same town.
So,
uh,
if there's no room,
if there's no room in a town,
for example,
if,
uh,
if too many people chose east of town,
then we allocate the surplus randomly.
We,
we,
we at the places,
uh,
randomly.
All right?
So then we,
uh,
then
randomize,
uh,
to ration.
People understand that.
So,
for example,
there's a hundred,
there's 100,000 places in east town.
So if 150,000 people chose East town,
you're going to have a two thirds chance of getting into east town and the rest
of it's gonna be allocated to Western.
All right,
that makes sense.
Actually,
I just need something to make things add up.
Okay.
So to do this,
I first of all need to decide who in the clause is tall and who in the class is
short.
I'm going to grab that mic again.
All right,
so let me just count backwards.
I guess we'll ignore this row.
So one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
possibly eight,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight.
Well maybe this.
Okay,
so,
so up to here,
this row and forwards,
you are short people.
You understand that everyone,
everyone forward of where I am now,
Rahul included is short.
Okay.
And the rest of you guys and the guys in the balcony to come see me anymore.
The guy isn't the balcony.
You are tall.
All right.
Short,
tall.
Okay.
So how many rows of these you have?
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
seven,
seven rows here,
right?
The right,
uh,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six.
We have seven rows of short people.
Okay.
All right.
And the rest of you are a tall mean.
I'm going to hope I split that evenly.
Okay.
And I'm going to cheat a little bit in the minutes.
You're going to have to choose which town you're going to live in.
And we'll do it by showing it by show of hands.
All right?
But before we do that,
I'm going to cheat a little bit by giving each of you an initial position.
This is irrelevant,
but I just wanted to just want to sort of set things up.
So what we'll do is we'll put,
we'll put,
uh,
this row to this row.
One,
two,
three,
four.
These rows,
your initial position isn't east town.
It doesn't matter.
You can move.
But your initial positions in east town,
so east,
east,
ever understand that yeast.
And these are heroes.
This row,
this row,
and this row,
you're in West town.
All right.
And these next four.
Oh,
so you guys,
you guys,
and you guys do it again.
This row,
this row,
and this row,
you're an east town and I notice I have this one and you're,
you're an east town as well.
Okay.
The up to his east town and the rest of you is in West town.
Everyone understand where they are.
Now let's do a test with the,
with the camera watching.
So if you are currently in east town,
raise your hands and if you're currently in west town,
raise your hands.
All right,
so I've,
I've set you up with a stripey pacman.
See over the stripey patent and notice that I've set things up so that slightly
more of the short people were in east town,
right?
And slightly more of the,
uh,
of the,
tall people.
I did that right?
I did that right.
We're in West town.
All right.
If,
if,
if I did that correctly,
I'm not sure I did actually.
But if I did that correctly,
slightly more of my short people started life in east town and slightly more of
my tall people started life in West town.
Okay,
so now think about it.
A seconds.
Remember,
these are your payoffs,
right?
That's a suspension of disbelief.
These your payoffs.
And in the minutes I want all the people who are choosing a east town to raise
their hands.
And then I'm going to do to count of three and don't cheat.
Don't look around you and see what's going on.
All right?
So really you all close your eyes.
All right,
everyone close.
Their eyes are on the room.
Close their eyes,
right?
I could do anything.
I'd be swimming naked.
All right.
All right,
so I will get your,
I suppose,
and the count of three everyone is choosing east town should raise their hands.
One,
two,
three.
All right,
so this is my east town where people can open their eyes.
Now look at the east town,
East town distribution.
So I've got this big block of East town here,
a little bit going on the wings,
little bit of spillage here.
I said,
let's just make it,
let's just check it.
So,
so those of you who didn't raise your hands just now in West town.
So West town,
people raise their hands.
All right.
I got a little bit of spillage here,
but basically I've got west town over here,
right?
That's all right.
Everyone understood what just happened?
Everyone saw it happens.
All right,
let's do it again.
That's not that.
That's,
that's where you are now.
Let's see what happens next time.
So once again,
close your eyes.
All right,
Don't communicate.
All right.
Everybody's who's a,
who's going to choose east town?
Raise their hands now.
All right,
so I've got pretty much all of these rows now,
or an east town.
I got a little bit of spillage here,
but basically I've got east town in the front.
I can onto the balcony.
What I've got in the balcony up there?
No hands up on the balcony.
That's typical.
All right.
So,
okay.
Okay.
All right.
They live in the balcony,
right.
So,
all right,
so I bet I've more or less,
but eastern here.
Where's my West town?
And raise your hands if in west town now and West town.
A little bit of spillage here,
but basically about West town in the bank.
All right,
let's do it one more time.
One more time.
I everyone understand where things were just now.
All right.
I May,
I'm leaving the hands up long enough.
Long enough.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let's try it again.
So East town we'll count of three.
One,
two,
three.
All right.
So here's my east town.
I'm more,
I'm pretty much any among the east town dwellers right now.
West town.
Raise your hands.
One,
two,
three.
And I'm pretty much in the West town dwellers right now.
And this is not a tall stripey.
All right.
We start off with the stripey pattern and we ended up,
we ended up how we ended up with pretty much the whole front of the room
choosing East town and the whole back of the room,
maybe including the balcony.
Me Choosing West town,
the bulky,
we're just flying over.
All right.
All right,
so everyone saw what happens.
All right.
Now can anyone what say what,
what's,
what's happened there?
Why did we end up like that?
How do we end up like that?
We started off with a stripey pattern,
right?
It was a little bit off from being kind of perfect because all of you by these
preferences would prefer to be in a town that was exactly 50 50 wasn't quite 50
50 but it wasn't far off actually.
All right,
and we pretty quickly ended up with all these short people.
You guys are short all living in East town and all of Utah people living in West
town.
It all of you pretty much ended up with a,
with a payoff of a half.
Some of you didn't know were a few DVN.
Two of my Devens who my guys who am I tall guys who ended up in east town.
Yeah,
so these guys,
it's fine,
but they end up with a pair of close to zero.
Right,
right,
right.
And,
and,
and who am I short deviants who ended up in West town?
It was a few,
not many of them.
It all works in a few of them,
but then they end up with a pair of zero as well.
Right.
But pretty much everyone else was ending up with a pay off close to a half,
close to a half,
and splitting down the middle of the room.
All right,
now,
now why?
What do we call that?
What do you call that process?
What's the outcome here?
Yeah,
so this is to say it again.
So this is segregation,
right?
We ended up getting the class to segregates on tall and short,
What is it?
The people,
it wasn't the people wanted desegregates right.
Where I gave you,
I gave you a preference is,
and I told you,
and you have to have these preferences,
which might actually will preferences that favored being in a mixed town.
But we very quickly settled down to a segregated,
uh,
distribution of a class.
All right.
Why,
what led to that as just talk it through a bit.
Well,
who has an opinion of what it was that kind of got us there?
Yes.
So Patrick,
shout out for the part of it.
This doesn't,
this doesn't speak to the club.
I mean I think what happened is basically,
because it was the first choice is simultaneous everyone,
the site lead,
bad situation,
all change to what was perceived to be a better situation.
So he sort of shot past that equilibrium where we were 50,
50.
Right,
right.
So I cheated a little bit by starting you off away from the 50 50 points and you
kind of went further very,
very quickly.
Now I want to say that I think with,
with a longer,
with a longer time period to play with,
I could have started you off,
uh,
just random,
right?
Let's choose whatever.
And if we played enough times,
my guess is we'd have ended up saving gated anyway.
It might not have been segregated with east here in west there.
It might've been the other way round,
but I'm pretty sure we'd have ended up segregated anyway.
All right.
I can't prove that because we wouldn't have enough time to do it.
I cheated by pushing us that way.
All right.
So what happened was,
is this,
right people who started off in the minority but not badly in the minority,
uh,
in,
who,
who are,
who are short guys in West town,
they moved to east town.
Right?
That was largely the rows here,
right?
You guys moved to West town and guys who ended up who I started off in the
minority,
I don't know.
I'm not even sure.
It was actually a minority,
uh,
who were tall guys and east town.
You guys drifted over at West town.
Is that right?
Okay,
well talk about this more in a second,
but let's just get some ideas down on,
on the board.
Well,
I dunno actually that while I'm,
while I'm down here,
it's a little bit more work.
All right,
so before we leave this,
I'm not,
I mean we leave talking about it.
Let's figure out what are the equilibria hair.
So what's an equilibrium of this game?
It's a pretty simple game.
It has lots of people,
two choices per person.
We're going to be doing guessing,
check here,
right?
So what people think the equilibrates and we get someone who hasn't spoken the
APP.
I surely can't have to cold call then it's an easy one.
What's an equilibrium here?
Somebody wasn't equally.
How about the gentleman here on it?
You would have ever guessed what an equilibrium is.
Everyone being segregated,
everyone being segregated.
Let's be a bit more precise.
So I claim there's two ways they can be segregated.
So,
so,
so spun out the two ways.
If all of the top people are in West town and all the shore people are in east
town or if all the tall people are in the West town,
good,
good.
And your name is.
So Greg is saying there's two ways to be segregated and each of them seems like
an equilibrium,
right?
Let's just spell it out to all the tall people.
Being in the East is one equilibrium and all the poor people being on the west
is the other equilibrium.
Both of those I claim or Greg claims,
but more carefully,
great claims.
Both of those are Nash Equilibria.
How do we check that they're nationally,
whatever they are,
you're right.
But how do we check that,
that the,
that they are in fact equilibrium.
We go about checking that they're equilibrate the guessing part is easy
checking,
whereas a bit of thought.
So what,
how do we check?
Uh,
yeah,
you check for profitable deviations.
So what's a,
what's a deviation here?
If,
if,
if all the tall or short people are an east town and all the tall people in West
town,
what's a deviation?
A deviation.
It's ignore the capacity constrained from an it,
uh,
a,
a deviation is for what are the short guys to move to West town?
That,
right?
So as the equilibrium,
that short guy was getting a payoff of what,
what was this pay off his or her pay off and equilibrium.
One half.
If he or she deviates and moves to Westtown.
Again,
ignoring the capacity constraints,
let's assume that they can,
if that short person moves to West town,
watch their payoff going to be zero.
So that's not a profitable deviation.
And conversely,
if we do the same from the other side,
for the tall people,
we'd find the same thing.
So we've just checked for that.
Isn't equilibrium because nobody can deviate profitably.
All right,
so we found to equilibrate here and if people have pointed out they are
segregated.
Now I claim that there's another equilibrium here,
which the other equilibrium here,
what's the other recruitment and I,
I should get the Mike right the way on the other side.
So let me let,
let me try and lean in here.
Lean my way.
Yeah,
can he can eat.
Thanks.
Good.
So if the,
if the,
if the crowded split exactly.
50 50 that would also be an equilibrium.
Right?
But the key word there is what the keyword cause to the 50 50 is the key word.
What's the other key word there?
Exacts.
All right.
It really has to be exact for this to work.
I know since I'm hand waving a bit because he Collibra always exact statements,
but can people see what's going on here?
So people split exactly 50 50 wide,
split the class down the middle.
I started off by saying it this way in to talk people and short people and I
might split the town down the middle and eastern West,
then everyone would've been happy and they'd have stayed put.
That's uh,
this gentleman's playing and I think it's,
that's correct.
All right.
But what's,
what's,
um,
suspicious if you like,
what's,
what's worrying about that equilibrium that isn't equilibrium?
What's worrying about that equilibrium,
that mixed equilibrium,
that integrated equilibrium.
All right.
Can get role.
How can we get the guy here?
Okay.
It's so weak nash equilibrium because while there's no,
there's no real incentive for you to deviate.
There's no incentive for you to not deviate either.
Good.
So,
so one thing that distinguishes,
thank you,
that's very good.
So one thing that distinguishes that equilibrium from the equilibria that we
were just looking at is it,
in some sense it's week,
whereas the other ones are straight.
What do we mean by that?
If we deviate away from this thing?
Exactly.
Mixed equilibrium.
Roughly speaking.
I'm [inaudible] a little bit of hand waving here,
but roughly speaking,
we're exactly in different.
All right.
It's true.
It's not strictly true because I guess by ourselves moving,
we're changing the balance a little bit,
but,
but nevertheless,
we know that if I pay smooth out the top,
it will be exactly right.
Right?
So at the,
at that ad,
that's a mixed equilibrium,
so I don't want to call it a mixed income.
Had that integrated eat whatever that an equilibrium.
I'm exactly in different about where I live,
both towns and look the same to me.
Right?
They call it east and west,
but they have the same mixture of tall and short people in that.
All right.
Where is it?
The segregated equilibria at the segregation equilibria?
I strictly prefer to go to the town in which I'm the majority.
I'm doing s having a strictly higher pay off half versus zero by being in the
town in which I'm in the majority.
All right,
so there's this,
there's this notion of strictness.
There's also a notion of stability here.
All right,
so I got,
I don't wanna be too formal here.
I want to give you in formal idea about why we might worry about stability.
So what do we mean by stability here?
Why?
Why do I think that that,
that,
that integrated equilibrium in which we divide the town's equally might not be
stable.
When we mean by that mean for the physicists in the room,
it should be an easy idea.
But for everyone,
I think it's a fairly intuitive idea.
Why has that not likely to be stable?
Anybody,
what's her name,
Chris.
If even one person deviates and all of a sudden everyone will prefer to deviate
to that completely segregated position.
Right?
Good.
So at that integrated equilibria,
if we move away from it a little bit,
right?
If it turns out that,
let's say one town has 5% more short people and the other town has 5% more tall
people,
right?
Then in some sense we're in trouble already.
All right?
We have when we haven't gone very far from this nice equilibrium,
but already we're in trouble because now all of the uh,
short people are going to prefer east town and all of the tall people I kind of
refer West town and in a few in a few moves we're very quickly going to be back
at segregation again.
Right.
It's not stable in the sense that we were a little bit off.
We're going to go a long way off and again,
I'm not being formal here,
but the informal idea I think is important.
All right.
Conversely,
those segregated equilibria because they were strictly collaborators,
they didn't want to have over that we're pointing out,
they're really pretty stable.
If we start close to 100% short people in east and close to 100% a tall people
in west and then we move it in a bit of weight.
So I shake you up a bit and I forced you not to be know I reallocated a few
people and then that you play,
I claim you'll go back to that equilibrium.
Is that right?
So the equilibrium that is integrated here,
it is an equilibrium.
It's only a week equilibrium and it's not very stable in some sense.
Whereas the segregated equilibria there clearly strict equilibria and they asked
people,
all right,
let's put some of this down on the board now,
partly because it feels weird for me being out there,
even if it doesn't for you.
All right.
All right,
so we've got this several equilibrate here.
We've got at least three and we'll come back and talk about whether there are
others in a minute.
We've got at least three equilibria.
Two of them are segregated.
Nash Equilibria in this game.
We have to
segregated.
Nah,
she when it wrap.
All right.
And they,
these corresponds to tool in east and short in west and vice versa.
And we,
and,
and we had a separate,
a separate one,
which was an integrated one.
Yeah.
Which was roughly half of each in each town.
All right,
so there's at least three equilibrate hair,
although the two separate ones are kind of the same.
And we argued that this,
these segregated equilibria
is segregated equilibria.
We're in some sense stable.
And they were strict equilibria in the sense that you preferred not to deviate.
All right?
Whereas these intimate of Equilibria,
these were actually perhaps not stable and again,
I'm not being for here,
so has to be careful.
I'll put it in inverted commerce and again,
I'm a little bit informal.
I kind of weak equilibrium.
All right.
No,
I want to bring up one other concept here,
which is the idea of a tipping point.
All right,
so this is a game that was introduced by a guy called shelling.
Shelling went on to win the Nobel prize largely for this,
I think certainly in law in large part for this one idea,
right?
This is a game that has a tipping point.
There are really two stable equilibria,
the segregation at one way or the segregation the other way.
And in between there's a tipping point beyond which if you,
if you've been on,
which if you go beyond which you go to the other equilibrium,
I said that very badly.
But if people get the idea that there there are too strict equilibria and if
we'd got beyond the point of a half half mics going the other way,
we can was off to the other equilibrium,
right?
And we already saw a game that had a tipping point when we pay the investment
game,
whether a two week,
there were two equilibria,
all invest and no one invest.
There was a natural tipping point in that game.
And the tipping point was having exactly 90% of you at best or at the point at
which you actually would want to flip over and go to the other equilibrium.
So this is a game that has a tipping point.
We can push people away from the equilibrium and they'll go and coming back and
they'll go and coming back and go and come and coming back.
And then,
but if we just push on a little bit beyond the half,
whoops,
look off to the other equilibrium.
Very dramatic change.
All right?
Is that seems like a lot an important idea in uh,
for example,
uh,
sociology.
So I've got these segregated equilibrate and they've got these integrative equal
a rat and this just make the other obvious remark,
uh,
which of these e w which of these equilibria is it is preferred by the
population.
Would they rather be in the integrative equilibrium given that these are their
pay offs or the segregated equilibrium,
but rather be an integrated one?
Right?
All right,
so here's a world in which they'd like to be.
In the end,
everybody would like to be in the intro to equilibrium.
This is not a prisoner's dilemma.
All right?
This is not a case that we've seen before,
but it turns out that you're likely to end up in these inefficient,
less preferred by everybody.
Segregated equal number.
All right?
However,
if we're subtle about this,
you might notice there's actually a 30.
Whenever I'm in this game for a little bit nerdy,
there's actually another equilibrium in this game.
So,
uh,
ally,
I need to give you your mic back.
I'm sorry.
That was the guy that uh,
in in gray,
mmm.
They've ever chooses one town,
the other,
regardless of whether they're tall or short
distributed.
Good.
So your name is nick.
Nick.
So Nick's pointing out,
this is actually hidden in here.
Let me put it on.
It doesn't sound like anything very realistic,
but let's just focus on just a second because I think that's an important lesson
here.
There's going to turn out to be important lessons.
The other recorder room is support.
Actually this is two of them.
It's everybody.
Everyone in the room shows east town.
What would happen while we'd have to find a way of assigning everybody.
All right.
So what we do is we essentially randomize over the room and half the room will
be an east town and half the room will be in west.
All right?
So there's this kind of silly equally reminiscence in which everyone does the
same thing and the way in which people actually get allocated is not by their
choice,
but by this detail of the group.
This detail of the original game,
which was if there was overcrowding,
we were going to randomize people.
All right,
so the is actually a 30 whatever,
which is,
oh there's two of these of course.
So all choose the same town
and get
randomize and to check out his new equilibrium.
It no,
just that if everyone else is choosing,
if everyone else is playing this strategy,
I've all choosing east town and allowing,
allowing the randomization device to place you,
then you're completely happy to do that.
Compete,
do the same thing.
All right,
so it is in fact an equal number.
So this is a slightly odd equilibrium here and there's immediate like game
theory lesson here.
This equilibrium sounds like something we might see in society.
This one certainly worth talking about.
It seems a natural part of the game.
This equilibrium seems to have nothing to do with anything that's really in the
world.
It's just a rising from a particular detail.
I threw into the model at the end to make things that up.
Is that right?
When I,
when I was setting up this model and describing reality,
I threw this in at the end.
Just say,
well,
we better do something just to make things add up otherwise otherwise towns are
going to be overcrowded.
Alright,
well it wasn't,
that's really out there in the real world.
It was just to make it a game.
So have to define things carefully and this seemingly innocent detail of my
modeling technique threw up another equilibrium,
right?
So there's a sort of warning lesson here.
The lesson is
seemingly irrelevant details.
I'm a game seemingly irrelevant details.
Things that aren't really attempts to capture reality,
they're just trying to get things through in a hurry
can end up mattering,
can matter,
it can lead your game to give you a prediction.
You really don't believe it.
Is that right?
And that's a very general lesson for those of you.
I'm going to go out and model things more widely.
There's a second lesson
here.
However,
the second lesson here is if in fact there's this randomization process was
available,
if in fact it was possible for everyone in the town to choose east town and then
have the local governments randomize you,
right?
Then if we use the law of large numbers,
if there's $100,000,
it's 200,000 people in all,
and they're all being randomized,
we're going to end up very,
very close in the limits exactly.
At the,
uh,
at integration.
Right?
And everyone's going to be better off.
Is that right?
All right.
So the other kind of strange thing here is by randomizing,
well,
I don't want to say randomizing.
I want to say
having
[inaudible]
randomize for you
ended up being better than choosing.
I ended up better
then what you might want to call it an active choice.
All right.
Here's an example of a place where by advocating the right to choose what my
town and simply,
uh,
by,
by all choosing east having society randomize for me,
we ended up better off,
slightly surprising result.
All right,
let's try and push this a little harder.
Get rid of that.
Nope.
Okay.
Let's try and draw some lessons.
We draw out some game through lessons already from this about irrelevant details
and about stability and so on.
Let's try and drive some other lessons here.
So one lesson might be a lesson in sociology.
I'm not a sociologist so I I uh,
wanted me to be careful,
I'll put it in inverted commas here.
Uh,
the social order,
the lesson is what in this game segregation is what resulted at least in the
stable equilibrium and you might be tempted if your an empirical sociologist to
go around the world and say,
look,
I see segregation everywhere.
I've gone from country to country,
from society to society and wherever I go I see segregation.
You might be tempted to conclude,
but that's because people prefer segregation and that might be right.
Right.
Nothing of this model.
This proves that it might be the facts that it might in fact be the case that
the reason you see a segregation in virtually every society is because
segregation preferred.
I'm not ruling that out here.
I'm just raising another [inaudible] what's the other hospitals?
The other possibility is it could be.
The preference is,
I like this roughly speaking,
people don't actually prefer segregation,
but when all people act in their own interest,
you end up with segregation anyway.
All right,
so the fact that we seeing segregation,
seeing segregation in this morning,
cool
in segregation does not imply,
does not imply that there's a preference for segregation.
It doesn't rule it out.
Of course.
What do you call them?
Conclude.
Just because you see segregation everywhere then necessarily people want
segregation and let me just take that outside of the context of segregation more
generally.
If you see a social phenomenon in society after society after society,
whether they were anthropologists going across the societies or a historian
going through societies in historical time and you see the same phenomenon that
each of these societies,
which results from the choices of thousands of different people you call
conclude from the fact that you see it in all of these societies,
the those people prefer it.
All you know is that each of their individual choices add up to this social
outcome that may or may not be something they prefer.
In this case is not all right.
That was what he's shutting his big idea all.
So I don't want to write that all out,
but it's,
it's kind of a,
it's a,
it's a huge idea.
I could've got him the Nobel prize.
Right?
All right,
great.
So you don't want to conclude from observation straight back to preference in
the strategic settings.
All right,
now this matters a little bit obviously in our own society because we live in a
robber segregated society.
Okay?
So,
uh,
I mean we didn't be,
be quite so coy as to talk about tall people and short people all the time.
What we're really talking about mostly I guess in our society is ethnic
segregation.
And we see this very dramatically in,
in,
in Connecticut for example.
So where we live in new haven,
at least if you go,
uh,
you know,
a few feet outside of the university,
you actually look where people living in new haven.
Uh,
we see that new haven is a fairly integrators town.
There's not hundreds,
hundreds grid of town,
but it has a fairly wide,
uh,
array of ff,
ethnicities.
All right?
But if you go upstairs and Connecticut,
did you go north ignoring half?
And if you go into the rural areas or Connecticut's,
you find something dramatically different.
Now,
how many of you have traveled around in,
in,
in rural Connecticut about some of you have.
So if quite shocking for me as a foreigner,
I came here,
so new haven and the towns along the coast are fairly integrated.
But if you drive into rural Connecticut use,
he's been quite different.
So this weekend for example,
I was up at the Dharma Fair.
How would you know what the Durham Ferris,
some of your nose,
the Darren Fair actually is very good.
It's a place where you can,
it's a biggest agricultural in Connecticut and you can take your kids there.
I have a four year old and a two year old and they discover it this fair that in
fact it is the case.
That cow saying moo and sheep say bar.
Who Knew?
Right?
That's,
that's a good thing.
So I don't want to knock the Darren Fair.
I think it's a good,
a good thing.
But if you're wondering around the DRM affair and you're a social scientist as
as I am,
I gas,
you can't help but be struck by,
um,
how would I put this without getting in trouble?
Um,
you would find more ethnic diversity at a Klan rally,
right?
This is,
this is not,
I mean,
this,
that's not gonna get me out of trouble.
There's gotta be some way of saying that it doesn't get me in trouble,
but you know what I mean.
Right,
right.
It is strikingly,
strikingly white at the darling.
All right?
We're only what it's about,
I think it's 18 miles from new haven.
It's a 20 minute drive from new haven.
All right?
It's a,
it's a public event,
20 minutes,
20 miles from new haven.
All right,
so this is a phenomenon.
One might be tempted to say,
ah,
this is because people choose,
people want clean.
People are choosing to go to the Darwin for her,
that choosing to some extent where they live in,
in Connecticut.
And you won't think the fact that we see this incredibly dramatic segregation
between,
uh,
activities in new haven and activities 20 miles away.
It's evident that people might actually prefer segregation and it just repeats.
I'm not,
I can't prove that it isn't right,
but we have to be at least aware of the possibility that he's got nothing to do
for it.
With a profit to segregation.
It could be the preference is look like the preference is above all right?
It could be that simply thousands of activities by thousands of individuals who
at least would prefer to be in the majority than,
than the,
they'd rather be in the majority,
not the minority,
but they'd like to be integrated leads to incredible segregation in the
aggregates.
All right,
so let's go out policy now.
So as I go down here,
I'm going more and more in trouble,
I'm sure.
Horrible as a foreigner,
right.
This is a big policy question in the u s right.
How many of you are unaware of the fact this is a big policy question in the u s
right,
right.
So at least since the 1960s,
this issue about segregation versus integration has been a hot button issue,
particularly in what,
in what circ?
Uh,
particularly in,
in,
in what part of,
uh,
of social life?
Uh,
yeah,
segregating schooling.
Okay.
So,
I'm sorry.
So Jessica is pointing out correctly that since the 1960s,
this has been an incredibly hot issue in the U S and we're talking about the
busing debate.
How many of you have not heard of busing?
How many of you have heard of Boston?
That's him.
Yeah.
All right.
So,
so it's slightly a,
a policy debate of 1960,
so people tend to forget it.
But in the 1960s and early seventies,
people were so worried about segregation in schools that they,
uh,
that,
children were bused from one neighborhood to another neighborhood to go to
school.
All right.
And this was an incredibly controversial issue in the U S and I'm not,
I don't want to take a position on it here.
I just want to point out that you could arrive at that policy by thinking about
this kind of model.
In fact,
this is not just a,
an issue of history.
If you read the newspapers last week,
uh,
including,
the,
uh,
the Yale daily,
you'll see that it's an issue today in Connecticut.
There's a,
there's a worry in Connecticut today,
typically around Hartford,
that the schools are still illegal,
illegally segregated,
right?
There's this,
that they're not,
not in compliance with the law.
All right,
so this continues to be an issue.
Uh,
let me take it to a slightly less contentious areas since that's obviously so
contentious and talk about and try and relate it back to the model a bit.
So in the model,
what we saw was if everyone shows to go to east town of everyone chose to go to
west town,
uh,
there was a policy,
there was a little bit like busing going on,
right?
If everyone chose to go to east town,
what we ended up with was randomized placement across the towns.
Is that right?
Right.
And that's a little bit like the Boston policy.
It says everybody should,
we take away people,
we,
uh,
take away people's active choice of their school and in place we just randomize
everybody.
Alright.
So leaving aside,
what happened in Connecticut's let's think about a school,
not a very good school,
but a school that's a little bit north of here.
So there's this school called Harvard.
All right?
And uh,
so that's,
Harvard is,
uh,
outside,
outside Boston.
All right.
And at least when I was there as a graduate student,
this was a hot issue in Harvard.
So whereas Yale has colleges,
Harvard has a houses,
but at the same thing,
right?
And,
uh,
these,
twins hissing me.
They are,
they are the same thing.
It's just the same name for maybe they're not the same.
Maybe there's some subtle difference,
but they're roughly speaking the same thing.
Right.
And I'm still getting it right.
And uh,
all right,
so these houses,
these houses at Harvard at least until about 1990,
I think roughly,
and I spent to me when I was there as a graduate student,
the way in which you ended up at a particular house was that was you chose which
house to be in.
All right?
And Harvard administrators started worrying.
So these houses started looking,
sort of taking on certain characteristics.
So,
for example,
there was a house,
I guess there still is called Eliot House.
And if you went to a,
as I used to occasionally as a graduate student,
go and eat at dinner at any house,
you'd meet all these people.
And it was kind of an odd experience because more than half of them had names
that just happened to be the same as the swim pool than just been built at
Harvard.
It was like,
right,
right.
Um,
and then if you went to,
um,
to Adam's house where I was actually at a,
you sir,
uh,
it was a very different mix of people and an extraordinary large portion of
them,
uh,
were a daughters of recently deposed Latin American dictators,
right.
Not exactly what you expect to meet at random.
And then just give you a third example.
There was a cow's called,
um,
I think it's wrong now.
Kirkland houses that right.
Kirkland House and Cuban house was known to be the Jock House,
the,
the athlete house.
And of course this being Harvard,
that meant that everyone that was comedian.
All right.
So,
so this was this worry you did the Harvard administrators.
All right.
So they,
they,
they were worried about it.
Are they presumably they were worried that uh,
uh,
you know,
little Ms Pinochet wasn't going to have a chance to meet Mr Master Gretzky or
something.
Right,
right.
Whatever it was.
All right.
So they did tell me about it.
Talk to what do they do?
What did,
what did the hub administrators do to change this,
to change this,
this,
uh,
outcome and one though.
Hi.
Yeah,
shocker that it's right,
but
when you're going to go into,
right,
right.
So what happened was they impose randomization.
They did exactly the policy that we described a up here.
All right.
This was essentially that policy and those is actually the policy that they
adopted the policy in which a house allocation was run.
It was randomly,
it was random,
which basically going through the policy,
Gail had all along.
All right,
so as happened in other cases in education,
Harvard arrived at the Yale solution eventually.
Alright.
Right.
All right.
So randomization,
randomization or more dramatic thing.
It's like busing our policies arrived at really,
because if we know of the existence of these models,
I'm not saying these are right or wrong,
it's not my position to say it.
The right and wrong.
I'm saying if you were going to all of you for these policies,
this might be a way in which you might argue for these bosses.
All right,
now I want to bring out the third lesson here.
And the third lesson here is once we,
we've drawn it,
well,
I already said I wouldn't repeat it.
Does a game theory lesson here about irrelevant details.
All right,
uh,
relevant details mastering.
But I want to bring in one more game theory lesson here.
So here we've been discussing randomization in this settings of the following
form,
uh,
in,
in the gay man,
the local governments randomize where you lived in the busing experiments.
Uh,
it was randomly chosen.
Who went to which school?
I guess it was done by social security number.
I don't know.
All right.
Uh,
and uh,
in Harvard it was an yell too.
There's some randomization about which college stroke house you're living,
right?
That's one way to achieve randomisation.
You can have it done centrally.
The central administration,
this local government,
the central government can randomly assign people.
But in principle there's another way to achieve randomization,
which the other way you could actually randomization,
it's another way you could just see randomisation both in this experiment and
elsewhere.
Uh,
rovers hammer way at the back there.
We kind of get them.
Each player in the game could randomly choose rice,
right?
So rather than having centralized randomization in principle,
you could get to the same outcome by having individual randomization.
All right,
so there's another possibility here,
which is individual randomisation.
In principle,
you could have everybody in the room decide that they're going to do is throw a
coin,
a fair coin,
each of them separately.
And if it comes up heads,
they'll go to east town.
And if it comes up,
tails,
they'll go to west town.
And if all of them do that and they all stick with it,
right?
Again,
by the law of large numbers will get pretty close to integrated towns.
But it won't have been some central authority doing the randomization.
It'll be each of you individually during the randomization.
Is that right?
All right,
so that's a little bit different.
And notice that if everyone else is doing this,
if everyone else is randomizing,
the towns will in fact be,
uh,
at least,
asymptotic we towns will be equally mixed and you'll be happy to randomize.
Why?
Because you'll be indifferent whether you end up in east town of West town,
so you might as well toss a coin anyway,
right?
So this is actually another nash equilibrium.
Let me get it loose here,
but we'll be much more precise in a moment.
All right,
there's another nash equilibrium yet another Nash equilibrium in this model and
it isn't it as silly in some sense.
It's how everyone go to la going and go into the east town and then having the
government randomize.
It's each person on their own tossing a coin and deciding where they go.
All right.
It sounds a little bit less like central planning and more like choice.
Now.
However,
as soon as we introduced the idea of individual randomization,
we've gone a little bit beyond where we've got two in the class.
Why?
Because so far in the class,
we've talked about strategies as the choices that are available to you and the
choices available to you.
Where go to the east town,
go to the West town or in the numbers game we played it was shoes a number or in
the alphabet,
the game we played,
it was choose Alpha or Beta or deciding whether to invest or not.
It was invest or don't invest and so on and so forth.
Right.
All right.
What we're seeing now is a new type of strategy and the new type of strategy is
to randomize over your existing strategies.
All right,
so we're introducing here in new notion that's going to occupy us for the rest
of the week,
and the new notion is a randomized,
okay.
Or as we to call them mixed strategies.
Okay.
All right,
so what is,
I'd be more formal next time,
but what is a mixed strategy?
It is a randomization over your pure strategists.
All right?
You're pure.
The strategies we've be dealt with in the course up to now.
From now on,
we're going to refer to those as pure strategies that your choices.
How am I going to expand your actual available choices to include all
randomizations over those?
Right?
This may seem a little weird too,
to make it seem a little bit less weird.
Let's move immediately to an example
done with this so I can use it.
So the example I wanted talk about is a game that I think is a bit,
is familiar to a number of you,
but I'll put up the payoffs and see
the parents look like this.
Each person has,
there's two players.
Each of them has three strategies and the payoff matrix looks as follows,
zero zero is down the lead diagonal.
I'm going around.
It's going to be one minus one minus one one minus one one one minus one,
one minus one minus one one.
Now without me putting any more letters up there,
what is this game?
Right?
So somebody to try it out.
And this is rock,
paper,
scissors,
right?
Rock,
paper,
scissors.
So I think I get this right.
This better be rock.
And this is to be scissors.
Actually this better be paper.
Okay.
All right.
This is rock paper says,
how many of you have not heard of rock,
paper,
scissors?
Good.
Uh,
uh,
the other day I was flicking channels and ESPN had a rock paper,
scissors contest.
I want to know who watches that.
Alright,
so this is a cut a fun game and it occurs all over the place.
It occurs even in episodes of the Simpsons.
So there's a,
I guess now by now famous episode of the Simpsons in which,
um,
the kids who are,
I guess Barton,
Lisa,
is that right?
Somebody help me out here at bottom with Easter.
Is that what they call?
It's a Bot and Lisa are playing rock,
paper,
scissors for some purpose,
uh,
to,
you know,
to allocate some priors and bars is seen to think,
did you can do an calcium's is seem to think rock,
paper,
scissors.
I love playing rock,
paper,
scissors,
rock rocks.
What could possibly be rock at least or his team to think?
Ah,
I love playing rock,
paper,
scissors.
Bart.
Always chooses rock.
All right,
that's pretty a hint of where we're going here.
That's a hint of where we're going.
This is a very simple game.
Rock,
paper,
scissors,
rock,
paper,
scissors.
But it's pretty obvious.
I hope that pure strategies in this game are probably not enough to to model
this guy.
Is that right?
So in particular,
I claim and if necessarily we'll prove that there is no nash equilibrium in pure
snatches in the strategies we've been looking,
looking at up to now,
there's no nash equilibrium in which people choose your strategies here.
All right,
so there's no nash equilibrium,
not from now on.
I'm going to use the term your strategies to mean the strategies we've been
looking at so far.
So by pure strategies here,
the set of PR strategies
is equal to the set rock,
your path and sisters.
All right?
What we've called strategy is up to now in the class.
Now can they want,
kind of want to see why there's not going to be a nash equilibrium in pure
strategies.
There's this talk it through.
So if one person plays rock,
the best response against rock is,
I just try that again.
You all know best response to rock his paper.
All right?
But if you paid paper,
the best response to paper is,
and the best ones to scissors is okay,
so everyone doesn't play this game.
Okay?
So clearly there's no,
there's not going to be a pure strategy,
Nashik,
whatever,
and wait because,
because any to attempt to look for best responses that the best ones,
which are,
that can lead to a cycle,
right?
Everyone see that there's no hope of finding to pure strategies that are best
response to each other because of that cycle,
right?
It's also a claim pretty easy to figure out what must be the national,
whatever.
I'm in this game,
we're going to prove it in a second,
more or less.
But nevertheless,
I think we actually know it.
So what is in fact the Nash Equilibrium Strategy in this game?
Uh,
it was,
it's good to get some,
we can put in cold call somebody what role do when I was chemical?
Somebody random.
Yeah,
just cold call somebody.
I'm sure they all know it.
To just cold call somebody to watch the,
yeah.
So the gentleman in the yellow,
what?
Watch the watch the Nash Equilibrium in this game
time allowing you mixed strategies.
Now it's,
I'm allowing you to randomize by allow you to randomize over your PR strategies.
I'm allowing you to play mixed strategies.
What it,
what's the mix strategy we think people are going to apply here.
Okay.
No idea.
You should be on that yet.
I want to play against you.
Is that it's up.
It's up.
Someone else pick Picada.
Yeah.
What do we think is likely to be the mixed trashy people are going to play on
this game and equilibrium?
No idea.
All right.
Who hasn't it?
We've gone from cells,
a champion,
rock,
paper,
scissors.
Blair playing each choice with one third bro.
Ability.
Thank you.
I think I thought that would be okay.
So I'm,
I'm amazed people live in play this with their siblings whenever they did and
there's lost a lot.
I don't know.
I don't know,
but all right,
so I claim I claim him as a guest.
I claim that the mash equilibrium is each player,
both planners,
each player chooses,
I'm going to call it a third,
a third,
a third.
And I said each player is playing the mix strategy.
A third,
a third,
which I'm sure I didn't catch your name.
Your name is,
uh,
which is Moses recommended strategy.
All right?
All right,
so each player,
he's going to play a third,
a third,
a third.
All right?
So I'm actually amazed that people didn't realize that.
Um,
and again,
I'm sort of puzzled as what happened in your childhood,
but never mind.
Let's figure out what in fact is the payoff to each of the pure,
pure strategies against this or whatever.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to show you that this will in fact be a nash
equilibrium by showing you payoffs.
Alright?
So watch the expected payoff.
So start off,
watch the expected payoff
of rock against a third,
a third,
and the other person is randomizing equally over rock,
paper,
scissors.
And I'm going to choose rock.
What would be my payoff?
My expected pay off?
Well,
I claim that with pro Valencia.
Third,
I'll meet another rock and get zero.
Okay,
come with Promos your third oh me to scissors and get minus one.
Hi,
I'm with problems.
A third how we'll meet paper and I said that wrong.
Let me try it again.
Probably a third.
Amit Rock and getting zero property,
a third Amit scissors and get positive one and it probably a third Amit paper
and get minus one does that right this time.
That's plus one minus one.
So my expected pay off is what?
It's a third of zero.
A third of plus one and a third of minus one for a total of zero.
Right.
And it's not hard to check that.
The same is true if I chose scissors,
I chose scissors and the other person is randomizing a third,
a third,
a third.
Then with promises here,
third I will get minus one with problems here.
Third,
I'll meet.
Analysis isn't get zero and we've probably a third.
I'll meet paper and get one and wants to get it nets out at Xero.
And finally if I played paper and once again I'm,
I'm going to meet somebody who is in fact randomizing a third,
a third,
a third over papers and scissors.
Then with probably a third,
I'll meet a rock and get one with probably a third.
I'll meet scissors and get minus one.
And with policy a third I'll meet paper and get zero.
Is that correct?
I want to happen with that.
How so?
It will net out at zero.
So each of the pure strategies here,
rock,
paper,
scissors.
I did actually,
I did rock,
scissors and paper.
You should have them when they play against a third,
a third,
a third.
The yield and expected payoff of zero.
All right.
What about playing the mix itself?
What's the expected payoff?
Oh,
of playing myself playing a third.
A third,
a third.
If I play against somebody who's playing a third,
All right.
What a third of the time I'm going to be playing rock.
Is that right?
A third of the time I'm going to be playing rock.
Alright.
So a third of the time I'm gonna be playing rock.
And then I'll get the expected payoff from playing rock against the third,
a third,
a third.
What was the expected payoff from playing rock against a third,
a third,
a third?
Zero.
All right,
so a third of the time I'm going to play rock and I'm going to get this zero.
And I was wishing I had color,
but let me just do it without colors.
Messily alright.
And a third of the time I'm going to be planning a scissors and then I'm going
to get the expected payoff from scissors against a third,
a third,
a third.
And what was the expected payoff of scissors against a third,
a third,
a third zero again.
All right,
so third of the time I'll place scissors.
I'll get this.
Zero.
All right.
And a third of the time I'll be playing paper,
in which case I'll get the payoff.
The expected payoff of paper against a third,
a third,
which once again it was zero.
So my total expected payoff is a third of zero plus a third of zero plus a third
of zero,
which for the math phobics in the room comes out as zero.
Okay?
Third of zero parts.
The third of Xero wasn't 30 zero,
zero.
All right?
So notice what we've shown here.
We've shown that if I play what I claim is the equilibrium of strategy.
A third,
a third,
a third against a third,
I get zero.
And if I played any other strategy,
I'd still get zero.
Is that right?
So therefore planning a third,
a third,
a third is indeed the best response or be it weekly.
It is indeed a best response.
And this is in fact a Nash Equilibrium,
right?
So what we've shown here is
we'll start with this.
What we've shown is in rock,
paper,
scissors,
rock,
paper,
scissors,
playing a third,
a third,
a third against
the other guy playing a third,
a third,
a third
is a best response.
All right?
Especially on the pack in the thing will be a vegetable.
But in particular it's a best response.
So
if both people play this,
one person pays a third,
a third,
and the other person plays a third,
a third.
This is a nash equilibrium.
So we'll belaboring a point that we all knew already playing a third,
a third,
a third.
Again,
if everyone pays a third,
a third,
that is a nash equilibrium.
It,
it's a little harder to show,
but it's true that that's the only equilibrium in the game.
And before you go,
if any of you know that people are running ESPN,
this is why watching this game on TV is unlikely to be exciting.
All right,
we'll come back and look at other mixed strategies and more interesting games on
Wednesday.